while titanfall 2 was an offense gem in
2016
suddenly longtime players are posting
videos stomping on
hordes of new players that's right new
players
the game just had one of its best weeks
in years
but why now and what exactly have new
players been missing
all this time this is why titanfall 2's
resurgence is well deserved
and why five years after the fact people
are just now discovering its brilliance
despite being one of the best fbs series
out there the franchise of titanfall has
been perpetually
[ __ ] and royally titanfall developer
respawn was co-founded by vince impella
and jason west
who broke away from activision after a
dispute you see the pearco founded
infinity ward
who created oh i don't know one of the
biggest gaming series of all time
for those of you who've seen your first
action welcome to the big time
call of duty which while successful
would hit
meteoric new heights of popularity with
call of duty modern warfare
and call of duty modern warfare 2. but
when ownership
rights and bonuses came into dispute
zapella and west broke away forming a
brand new company to be backed by ea
respawn entertainment with a reputation
for great games and funding secured the
brand new team revealed their first
project to be released in 2014
titanfall however this is when things
went awry
the first time 2013 and 2014 marked the
start of a brand new console war
one between the xbox one and playstation
4.
titanfall was locked in as an exclusive
to the xbox one and windows via origin
and would be one of the first xbox one
games releasing just a few months after
the system itself
but as the console war pressed on the
playstation 4 proved to be the victor
and titanfall was quickly forgotten
while titanfall received
massive praise and reviews and best of
awards the game lacked any form of a
traditional single player
leaving many potential customers
uninterested
ea never released sales figures and the
initial buzz quickly died
with this one month later xbox 360
release receiving relatively small press
but it was still a great game responded
honed each mechanic to perfection the
smoothness and speed of wall running
the ability to learn and perfect speedy
routes on maps
the relationship between pilots and
their titan it's easy to forget that
before
titanfall mex and many games were clunky
hard to control and often had no escape
but in titanfall the cycle of farming
grunts
killing pilots calling in a titan and
then ejecting to do it all over again
often without dying had a sublime loop
respawn even designed the smart pistol
which auto targeted enemies
so that older players could enjoy the
game by focusing more movement than
aiming
even the leveling system was different
to become a gen 10 pilot you were forced
to learn to get good
with a wide variety of weapons and
titans rather than just stick to your
favorite loadout
and fortunately a sequel was announced
and set to release cross
platform in 2016. titanfall 2 would
feature a revamped multiplayer
and include a more traditional single
player campaign
as opposed to the original game telling
his story through story focused
multiplayer matches
but despite having an incredible
property on their hands
ea uh
ea decided to release its much
anticipated battlefield on october 21
2016
and titanfall 2 the following week
october 28
2016 meanwhile activision's call of duty
infinite warfare was set to release
just one week after that november 4
2016. so for whatever reason
titanfall 2's release was sandwiched in
between the newest entries
of the two largest first-person shooter
franchises around
so it's unsurprising the game got lost
in the shuffle
to add insult to injury doom 2016 had
also released just a few months prior
the same year so while titanfall 2
featured not
only an incredible multiplayer
experience over a year of free
post-launch content
including new weapons a titan maps and
modes and also refined and fast-paced
first-person shooter campaign
most medium praise was centered around
doom's return to the spotlight
and its own incredible single player
despite
all of this and a release window that
worked against them
respawn took the titanfall universe back
to the drawing board
they began work on a title that they had
to convince ea to allow them to make
and one that would end up being one of
ea's most successful shooters
at the time following the troubling
launches of battlefront 2
and anthem apex legends despite being a
fantastic battle royale game set in the
titanfall universe
it wasn't the game that long time
titanfall fans had hoped for
it didn't have wall running or even
titans and most definitely didn't tackle
a pretty big cliffhanger around what
happened to bt at the end of titanfall
2.
upon apex legend's release respawn
revealed titanfall 3 wasn't
even in development though followed up
by saying a new titanfall experience is
being worked on
even then titanfall fans kept playing
and explaining to apex players where the
game had come from and at least
recently it seems they've paid off
and finally we come to 2020 where
titanfall 2 was released
outside of origin and to steam this
definitely bolstered the player base
but this past weekend took the crown
from april 30th to may 3rd
titanfall 2 was made free to play on
steam and its numbers
skyrocketed hitting its highest ever
concurrent player base
so now that there's a brand new swell of
players hitting titanfall 2
it turns out they've been missing one of
the best shooters outside of battlefield
and call of duty
its movement mechanics are absolutely
astounding and apex legends owes almost
all of its design to it
pilots in titanfall can seamlessly
parkour across environments
running along walls and double jumping
all this feels incredibly intuitive and
smooth
making the pilot the agile mouse in
what's essentially a blown up game of
cat and mouse
the titans form the cat in this analogy
with them being slower and more
lumbering
but more devastatingly powerful and as a
pilot you're allowed to act as both the
cat
and the mouse as you can freely pilot a
titan or exit when situations get sticky
it's this well-crafted balancing act
between the two elements
and fantastic multiplayer map design
that makes titanfall 2 stand out amongst
its competitors the game took what was
an award-winning multiplayer that not
many had played from the original game
and iterated on it further to hammer in
on what made it fun
and what could be added to further
explore those concepts
even the single player was incredibly
well crafted
with a slew of unique mechanics and
interesting areas regularly being
presented to the player and immediately
taken away once the mechanics started to
grow stale
take the 5th mission effecting cause
which sees your protagonist jumping back
and forth on the timestream
this mechanic was introduced in this
mission fleshed out in an organic and
fun way
and then immediately dropped as soon as
players complete the mission
before the mechanic overstays its
welcome another personal love of mine
was the fourth mission
into the abyss which involved ever
increasing platform challenges which
test your skills as a pilot in a super
creative way
the mission also featured you breaking
into and out of dynamic testing
facilities
varying the terrain and allowing for
titan battles within the level
the fact that some of these facilities
were constructed after you would
platform
onto them was only the icing on the cake
all of this was made possible thanks to
respawn's design philosophy of
action blocks in designing titanfall 2
the team focused on making everything
shine through gameplay
so they would have designers typically
on their own create
exceedingly quick prototypes of
different creative ways to play the game
if these didn't work the idea was
quickly scrapped but
if it worked it was then iterated on
this allowed for them to eventually
build out 45 different action blocks
with unique types of gameplay
while not all made it directly into the
game the overall idea and tone would
so now that even more players have been
introduced to titanfall 2
the question of titanfall 3 still
lingers and if it will
ever happen
[Music]
last we heard according to vince impella
due to the success of apex legends
the company's resources would be focused
on supporting that and titanfall 3's
plans would be pushed
a little further this was over a year
ago so we can only hope that titanfall
2's recent rise in popularity means that
we'll actually hear something a little
more concrete about a third installment
and speaking of which here are some
things we hope to see in a titanfall 3.
[Music]
well we have a lot of ideas for what we
want to see but let us know in the
comments if you'd like to see a video
about that or what you'd want in the
titanfall 3
and if you enjoyed this video we'd
appreciate a like and subscribe to show
us that you'd like more
and i'll see you guys next time
you